-On va retrouver avec plaisir,
en direct de Bercy, France Gall.
Dans combien de temps
allez-vous sur scène ?
-Eh bien, dans 35 mn,
si il est 20h25.
-Il est 20h29,
donc, dans 30 mn.
-On va peut-être avoir
quelques minutes de retard.
C'est le premier jour, donc je ne
pense pas que ça commence à l'heure.
-Le trac ?
-Je ne dirais pas le trac..
..mais je dirais plutôt
une grande émotion.
C'est beaucoup d'émotion
que je ressens.
Et je ne veux pas me laisser
submerger par l'émotion..
..parce que à la répétition
générale, tout à l'heure,
..ça m'est arrivée et dans ce
cas là je ne peux pas chanter.
Donc, c'est dramatique pour ceux
qui viennent voir une chanteuse.
-Avant de poursuivre,
un extrait de votre répétition.
-Ah bon ? Déjà ?!
-Oui, regardons ensemble.
-TOUT CE QU'ELLE DEMANDE...
-C'est de pouvoir comprendre.
-CE QU'ELLE FAIT LA...
MADEMOISELLE TCHANG.
-Si vous savez être tendre...
Elle se rapproche de vous.
-SANS QUE VOS YEUX DEMANDENT...
-Les siens se font plus doux.
-France Gall, vous avez dit
il y a un instant "émotion".
Est-ce que Pauline et Raphaël
seront dans la salle ?
-Pauline et Raphaël seront là.
D'ailleurs, Raphaël n'est pas loin.
J'aurai tous les gens que j'aime
et qu'ils m'aiment, ce soir,
..plus tout ceux
que je ne connais pas.
Et je suis très impressionnée..
..par tout cet amour..
..qui est dégagé
de tous ces gens.
-Pauline et Raphaël
qui sont vos enfants.
Il y a une certaine presse
très impudique qui a exploité..
..à l'extrême ce qui
vous est arrivée récemment.
Comment avez-vous pu résister,
à ce que j'appelle, un voyeurisme ?
-Je n'ai pas pu résister.
Cette presse
s'est emparée de moi..
..tout comme ce concert
s'est emparé de moi,
..mais j'espère bien qu'elle
va me lâcher, maintenant..
..que le cancer m'a lâchée. Donc,
ça devrait rentrer dans l'ordre.
-Qui sont ces jeunes danseurs
qui vont danser ce soir avec vous ?
C'est la banlieue
qui danse à Bercy ?
-C'est la banlieue qui
déboule sur la scène de Bercy.
Ces personnes font vraiment
parties de la vie, maintenant.
Et ça ne doit pas être des exclus.
Ils ont importé, créé une mode,
..une façon de bouger,
de s'habiller, de chanter...
Et c'est des gens
avec qui je me sens bien..
..et que j'ai eu envie d'avoir
autour de moi, sur scène,
..et je les adore.
On va s'embarquer..
..pendant un petit moment..
..comme ça, ensemble.
-Merci, France Gall. Bon spectacle.
-Merci de m'avoir reçue.
Au revoir.